So last week, I did a segment that I received
a ton of positive feedback about and it
generated some really good discussions
about deprogramming cultists and those
who have been brainwashed by disinformation.
As a reminder, the YouTube video was called I
confronted an anti Voxer. It didn't go well. Well,
and in that video, I chronicled an email exchange
I had with a covid anti vaccine person who
emailed me saying that I was being paid to promote
vaccines which aren't really vaccines and which
don't work anyway, and which are killing people.
And when I asked her for the sources for that
information, she ran away and provided nothing.
Well, this segment, aside from being instructive
in itself, also generated a ton of responses from
even more anti vaccine people all
coming out of the woodwork to attack me,
all equally uninformed, all sending me even
more outrageous emails. It was like cascading
and tiebacks inbox explosions. So because people
found last week's clip so interesting, I chose
just what I mean. I can't respond to all these. I
chose one of the subsequent emails to respond to
and I'll show you how that one went.
And it's basically just as bad.
All right. The follow up. I got an email from a
woman named Brittany who wrote to me responding
to my email exchange from last week with
Amy saying, quote, How can you promote
these unsafe vaccines? I'm sure you heard of the
nurse who fainted after getting her covid vaccine
and then they tried to replace her after she
died because of it. Britney sends me a link to a
website called Leith's A Humane Life WordPress dot
com, which is some kind of poorly formatted blog
which claims that the nurse who fainted after
getting the vaccine is actually dead and has
been replaced by a lookalike but a poor enough
look alike that I guess Britney can tell it's
not actually the same person. Now, initially, I
ignored this because it's so dumb and has been so
widely debunked. We know that the nurse didn't
die. We know there's lots of people who just
faint around needles. We don't know if this nurse
fainted as a real reaction to being vaccinated
specifically by this vaccine or she just faints
around needles to sort of vasovagal incident.
But most importantly, she didn't die. But I didn't
respond because it seemed like a waste of time.
But Britney was not to be ignored. Brittany was
persistent and she followed up, emailing me again,
saying, I sent you proof about the vaccines
causing deaths. I haven't heard back. So I assume
either you haven't had time to look at it or just
like everyone else, you don't want the truth.
Fraud is a serious thing, and that's what all
this is. So I don't understand why things are
being covered up. It will all come out in
court. So I don't know what else to say,
just that at least if you took time to read this.
Thanks for your time. So now I did write back
since Britney really seems to want an answer. I
wrote back to Britney and I said that nurse didn't
die. None of your links were reputable. Here is
a reputable source, Reuters. And I link Britney
to a Reuters article which reports including
naming the nurse and citing actual statements
from people on the record. The nurse who
fainted after covid-19 vaccine did not die.
Catholic Health Initiatives Memorial
Hospital in Chattanooga, Tennessee,
where nurse manager Tiffany Dover works, confirmed
to Reuters that she is well, to which our friend
Brittany wrote. Remember, Britney first was saying
the fact that you're not responding, it's because
clearly what I sent you was true. The nurse died.
I write Britney back and explain to her what
actually is going on. And Britney writes back
and without addressing the facts, says simply,
quote, I don't understand how you could cover
for these people. You know, the proof is solid,
but that's on you. Justice will come now.
As we discussed last week, every time
I show something like this or some of the hate
mail that I get, people write in and say, David,
these aren't people who are just wrong. These
people are clearly suffering from mental illness,
often paranoid delusions. Now, I certainly can't
diagnose that. I don't know how my audience can,
but the mental illness component in general is
something that can't be ignored. But either way,
taking this at face value, someone who believes
lessa humane life, that WordPress dotcom without
any citations of. A specific report from Reuters
with sourced links and naming individuals that
are giving statements, that's not someone I think
I can get back to reality, mental illness or not.
That's just a pragmatic reality. And the
problem ultimately is we need to get these folks
vaccinated in order to build herd immunity. So
it's not merely an academic or theoretical thing
to figure out, like how can we reach them if they
all don't, depending on how many of them they are?
And based on the herd immunity numbers we're
looking at right now, requirements that we're
looking at now, at least some of these folks are
going to have to get vaccinated for us to really
achieve herd immunity. That's my only concern. You
know, saying this person is just nuts or this is a
bad person or this is a liar or this is someone
who's mentally ill. It's a curious question,
but less relevant to actually figuring out
how to deal with this. And unfortunately,
I don't have an answer. I'm interested in
hearing from you if you think you have one.